you you showed up for jury duty and then
you posted I believe we have a photo of
you with your juror badge you don't look
like a responsible did you they didn't
pick you
well I I said yeah I showed up and then
the the way it works is here in LA is if
you you sit and wait in a room all day
and and and then if you don't get called
into a jury or into the voir dear
process then you're let go and you're
done right so I effectively did my jury
duty but I didn't have to sit on on an
actual jury that said don't think I
didn't tweet about it to brag about my
civic duty that I do you think you'd be
it's funny because you have encrypt me
if I'm wrong but you look if you had not
made it big in show business you look
like a guy it would have been a good
lawyer I would have been an awesome
lawyer you think you would have been a
good lawyer yeah I would have been an
exceptional lawyer it's not that hard
what do you mean sometimes I'll
demonstrate
all you got to do is sort of pace around
and lean on things you know
biro you have to know a lot of stuff
that you just kind of you just kind of
own the space and stick your butt out a
little bit and mr. O'Brien where were
you on the night of December 10th okay I
was at a friend's holiday party a
friend's holiday party you think that's
what you just repeat what they say
they're just repeated up and then you
say I see I see so like a friend's
holiday party I see I see and and who
might this friend have been mr. O'Brien
uh it was it was Will Arnett Will Arnett
oh so not just any friend a name
dropping celebrity friends yeah I guess
okay now you're expecting the ladies and
gentlemen of this jury to believe that a
very tan handsome hirsute gentleman like
William Arnett would have in his
domicile the likes of you a red-headed
interloper yes I'm saying that yes okay
all right well I would just have to say
that that is bolder - so what year admit
that you want their fine I wasn't there
I was at Kendrick Lamar's house
all right I was I was in a bath and I
was doing Sudoku what did you lose your
virginity okay how does this happen how
does this have anything to do with
anything
answer the question mr. O'Brien's fine
15 age 15 the year 2015 okay what are
you objecting to here that I'm not
guilty of anything
sustained hey I hear
are you sure you've actually been in a
courtroom bailiff now you're just saying
words gavel what did you think I'm gonna
southern judge why are you involved
suddenly you woke me up from my nap now
reveal yourself you can not you try to
convince me this is real hair I don't
even believe this crap you're happy you
know who'd wear a hairpiece like that I
don't know who you are
now that's just so you think that's all
it takes that's all it takes yeah I mean
I'll admit we got off the rails a little
bit there but thank you yeah and I think
if if anything I made a very compelling
case that I would be a horrific lawyer
you would be a great lawyer in 1905 yeah
I think and if nothing was at stake
right right those things lined up I was
like a parking ticket lawyer for Model
T's South Carolina you'd be alright
you